the following trailer is written as for
spoilers
[Music]
when the world hangs in the balance tom
cruise will hang
and balance in the franchise that keeps
pushing him to top the last one
until he dies making one of these and we
examine our own role in this deadly game
of stunt chicken
but until then you jump from that roof
you jump good boy
whoa mission impossible
fall out rejoin the impossible mission
force
on their most dangerous mission yet
getting their hands on some balls
as ethan hunt loses his balls tracks the
balls down
and has his best friends and ex-wife
work together to stop those balls from
exploding
i don't have enough hands tom buddy we
know you still got it
you have to ram it down our throats with
the metaphors
hmm you've seen every mi yet
so of course you were thrilled when
solomon lane returned
no you don't remember him well you do
remember the badass mi6 agent ilsa
no that's his wife from mi3 that's just
some random cop
that's kitty holmes okay that's her and
you remember the evil syndicate right
that's hydra that's spectre fine
forget everything you never remembered
in the first place because our heroes
are up against the apostles
and they've got a plan to wipe out a
third of the global population
that's thanos i said a third not half
they're going to starve one-third of the
world's population
look movie i'm here to watch tom hang
from stuff we're six missions in and i
still call the ving rhames character
ving rhames
even the people in the film scene lost
this time it's complicated
what the hell is he doing what the hell
is he doing what the hell are you doing
i don't understand what i'm involved in
what am i involved in why'd you have to
make this so
[ __ ] complicated joining the gang
or if you saw the trailer betraying the
gang is the secret agent august walker
a role that cements henry cavill as the
new king of men's room scenes
he's a spy who could go undercover as
anyone from an nfl linebacker
to haggar from final fight
[Music]
complete with arms that require a reload
and a mustache so powerful
it could [ __ ] the dc eu so you know
it's going to go down when he finally
faces off against his most brutal foe
yet
alec baldwin
alec if you wanted out of the franchise
just disappear like jeremy renner did
or paula patton or tandy newton or
jonathan reese myers
or lawrence fishburne or anthony hopkins
where do these people go
are they the apostles so if you like the
same potent mix of intrigue and cardio
as the last five of these things
and don't mind that they still lean on
the mass trick pretty hard
or use the same halo jump sequence as
two other bad robot productions
or have a weirdly similar ending to
return of the king
enjoy one of the best action movies of
the year
because the next one might be his last
oh tom you've given us enough
stop starring
the man from swole theta hunt
i'm the hat man skip up a butter pop
benji man's buttons you know because
he's manning the buttons
it's me rebecca ferguson hannibal
lechers
scarlett johansson scarlett johansson
wow what a chameleon jack tryin
and [ __ ] news
stuntman v superman tom of justice
have a seat the nubra river valley isn't
in ving rang's contract that he never
has to stand up
who lives in a pineapple under the sea
josh peck gives me goosebumps
they did surgery on a grape
you sit on a throne of wise
we are young life is fun
to honest trailer